I'm joined today by dr. Steven Boozer
who's a clinical psychiatrist also a
former major in the United States Air
Force he's an editor along with Leonard
cruise who's been a guest on the program
of a clear and present danger narcissism
in the era of President Trump so let's
start if we can with the recent
assessment that was done of Donald Trump
the Montreal cognitive assessment done
as part of what was really a physical
exam by the White House dr. Ronnie
Jackson from a medical perspective how
valuable is that 30-point assessment in
figuring out whether a patient might be
experiencing some of the early signs of
cognitive decline for cognitive decline
it's a good test but only in the more
severe cases you know a lot of people
have been looking since that you know
report at the Montreal cognitive
assessment and when you look at it it's
a very basic exam you need to name to be
animals or a masterís a camel and a lion
need to do very simple arithmetic you
know you need to draw the face of a
clock so it's really not you know
high-level valuation now it is good if
somebody had severe dementia if somebody
had clinically severe Alzheimer's
disease those things can be difficult to
do but it's really about a good test of
the Kondo bilities you need to be
presidency yeah I mean when I saw that
you get six out of 30 points you get 20%
for just telling the interviewer the
date and city where the exam is being
conducted that strikes me as testing for
something far more advanced than what is
even being sort of hypothesized about
Donald Trump right right it's not bad as
a kindergarten enters exam if you want
to see if your child's rape in the
garden it would be good for that or if
you had a severe question of Alzheimer's
disease but again the complexities of
running the government you know that is
by far you know not a suitable test the
other concern is Trump himself
supposedly asked for the exam and that's
highly unusual as
a clinician you know we're always
suspect if a patient asks for a specific
test this is no way to know that that
patient didn't prep area for that test
can you talk to us a little bit more
about what would be a more accurate way
of testing for what it is that is sort
of concerning about Trump's behavior
right there have been a number of
concerns around your president Trump
really since the beginning of the
election process back in 2016 you know
one concern was narcissism we put out a
book clear and present danger nurses him
the era of President Trump where we
looked at narcissistic elements within
it and there's been a lot written a lot
spoken of you know since then there's
further concerns of emotional stability
I wrote a piece in New York Times about
you would he be safe you know with the
nuclear reliability yeah criterion and
then there's the third piece which
you've alluded to today which is
cognitive abilities when you look at a
71 year old gentleman the oldest person
to enter his first term in the
presidency who has unusual judgments who
has declining vocabulary with reliance
on superlatives that yeah has difficulty
completing of thoughts there are
increasing concerns that somebody like
that may indeed have a cognitive
impairment the only good way to assess
that would be a full neuropsychological
evaluation which is you know three to
eight hours in duration it's not a ten
minute you know quickening a manual task
but it's an in-depth you know
psychological test and by a
neuropsychologist it really root out
early you know cognitive impairments
nobody is saying that he's got severe
dementia at this point but what many are
concerned of does he have early
continents you know for somebody who's
in there some of these we now know that
at some point during his presidency
Ronald Reagan was already experiencing
some cognitive decline as a result of
Alzheimer's is your sense that even
Reagan at that time would have passed
the Montreal cognitive assessment
most likely of course it's impossible to
answer that because as far as I know he
didn't have the test but correct at the
the point where Ronald Reagan was in
office and there were people with
concerns it would have been quite easy
to pass the Montreal cognitive
assessment I suspect that's a guess of
course but that is not a native thought
it has mass so I know that there will be
people who watch this interview listen
to this interview doctor and they will
say wait hold on a second
what happened to this principle of never
evaluating or even approximating
possible diagnosis for someone that a
psychiatrist has not examined directly
and in person isn't that what dr. beYOU
sir is doing he's using media clips and
appearances of Donald Trump to
hypothesize about what may be going on
cognitively and that is something that
the medical community community looks
down upon can you talk a little bit
about that and how those sort of stand
there have shifted over time with regard
to certain types of conditions you're
quite right there's only a debate
particularly the American Psychiatric
Association and whether it's reasonable
to diagnose a public figure from a park
and that's known as the Barry Goldwater
rule going back to the 1964 election
between LBJ and Barry Goldwater and it's
been widely accepted mostly that
psychiatrists and psychologists
shouldn't formally diagnosed a
politician or anybody in the public eye
based solely on observed criterion and
in our book we actually talk a lot about
that we have an entire chapter on the
Goldwater rule and we actually had read
mostly with the Goldwater rule and I've
been very careful both of my writing and
my public appearance is to not diagnose
stand down from with anything now that
doesn't mean we can't be concerned with
what we see that doesn't mean we can't
raise alarms and doesn't mean we can't
urge further evaluation so while I can't
and won't formally diagnosing president
Trump with a narcissistic sound disorder
with emotional instability you know with
a
decline or impairment I can certainly
say I've seen ya evidence you know
symptoms that that any reasonable person
would want you in further evaluation
remember this is the the man who as
president you know should he wake up
tomorrow morning and decide he wants to
launch a nuclear attack those nuclear
missiles then in the air and five
minutes and those missiles cannot be
recalled the cannon be deported they
will strike their target that could lead
to a full-scale nuclear exchange which
really could and civilization as we know
it on the planet so do you want somebody
that we're concerned about that destroy
the planet in five minutes time that you
feel comfortable ignoring an evaluation
not getting further information why do
we not at least want that evaluation to
be option to protect the safety of the
American people yeah I mean I would say
on the basis of identifying a giraffe
and a tiger I would say I don't want him
having the button if he could have
identified like a capybara in that exam
you might be able to convince me
otherwise we left once let's talk about
the nuclear weapon aspect of it what
specifically about all the different
behaviors makes you most concerned when
it comes to that example that you've
mentioned twice now the nuclear launch
capability that trump has as president
exactly the nuclear concern has been one
of my stronger concerns more recently
well he spoke a lot about narcissism
early on in the campaign my bigger
concern currently is is about nuclear or
yes accessibility I served 12 years in
the Air Force and as a psychiatrist one
of my roles was to evaluate military
personnel to see if they were fit for
duty and if they were working with
nuclear material the criterion for
fitness for duty was that much stronger
Department of Defense to regulation 52
ten-point 42 lays it out it says only
those personnel with the highest degree
of reliability trustworthiness conduct
and behavior
she'll be allowed to work in the
vicinity of nuclear weapons they got me
thinking suppose President Trump were
instead Airmen
and supposed airman Trump was stationed
at the base I would zap and suppose had
a clear outside evidence that airman
Trump was engaged in sexually abusive
behavior towards women that he was
cyberbullying on Twitter that is prone
to erratic emotional states that he was
paranoid at times about being surveilled
or persecuted unjustly and that he had
times of making highly distorted if not
frankly untruthful comments would I be
willing to certify airman Trump has
nuclear ready under their criterion my
answer was immediately no absolutely not
not without further a psychological
evaluation something like that we would
have done much more testing to see will
they be safer on nuclear weapons so
that's the great irony then that the
entire nuclear chain of command from the
air and in the missile silo to the
Chairman the Joint Chiefs of Staff are
all held to this very high degree of
psychological stability and readiness
except one person and that's the United
States the very person who has his
finger on the nuclear button there was
actually other examples of that as well
I mean we talked about with these Access
Hollywood you know grab them by the you
know what tapes how the other person on
those tapes the host of the program
Billy Bush he lost his job and Trump
went on to become president of the
United States the the the theme of the
different standards seems to be a more
and more common one doesn't it it does
it really does and that gets to what can
we do about this you know if the stakes
are really that high if the world could
be plunged into clear war in five
minutes with catastrophic consequences
you know why do we have the whole chain
of command
under you know tight scrutiny except you
know the one person the person the
United States there are actually a
number of initiatives in Congress as we
speak to to help this to add to the
safety and security of American people
one is House bill six six nine with the
Senate bill 200 version sponsored by
representative Liu Liu and Senator
Markey that's the restriction for the
first use of nuclear weapons Act of 2017
which basically states that no president
will have the authority to launch a
first strike nuclear attack without the
consent of Congress now if there's a
Italian need it if somebody attacks us
we can instantly attack that but were
there to be put into law you know
president would be allowed to initiate
that attack and we think of it why do we
need to destroy the planet in five
minutes when we could just as easily
destroy the planet in three to four days
to liberation or perhaps get a different
solution over those days I'd like to
talk a little bit about narcissistic
personality disorder my dad who's also a
psychiatrist but was trained in
Argentina sort of half jokingly once
said to me narcissistic personality
disorder is what we developed to be able
to assign a diagnosis to people who are
just flat-out insufferable and of course
he was half kidding when he said that
but the right question is when it comes
to the fitness to serve as president
narcissistic personality disorder is not
in the same league as some form of
cognitive decline or dementia right
we're talking about two different things
what indeed depending how we define it
there's narcissistic traits there's
narcissistic personality style in this
narcissistic personality disorder you
know those are in a spectrum of severity
and it's really hard to to determine you
know which of those may be going on
again about you know further evaluation
cognitive deterioration though is so
much more clear and dangerous and
verifiable on testing not that
narcissism isn't but if somebody has
early cognitive impairments that will
likely progress and is highly dangerous
yeah in this kind of condition so yeah I
think we're talking about a whole
different concern at that level last
thing I want to touch on did you see
that very bizarre video of Trump like he
had a huge wad of chewing gum in his
mouth when he was giving a speech and
then signing an executive order that's
been the subject of lots of speculation
in terms of loose dentures or whatever
else are you familiar with that video
there are so many videos it's actually
hard to say because I've seen President
Trump in numerous cases yes I do believe
I know the one year referring to you
with that yes so we were ultimately told
that that was the result of dry mouth
due to a medication
the president was taking there was
speculation about loose dentures but
really rich people tend to have dental
implants not dentures and in any case we
were told after the medical exam Trump
doesn't have dentures does that entire
incident feel okay to you now in terms
of we've gotten a satisfactory
explanation or is it still a suspect
incident in your mind well it's
certainly not okay particularly the
broader context if that was really the
only event that we were concerned about
and you maybe it could be explained away
with that but if you spend five minutes
on Google and just type in unusual
behavior by person Trump on YouTube you
will find enormous amounts of material
out there all on video all captured you
know this is a man who really struggles
to complete a sentence you know his
sentences are long they're run off
repetitive he uses these superlatives
you know in a almost no changing fashion
you really get the sense that something
just isn't right in a mocha the Montreal
cognitive assessment is not reassuring
that does not give us significant
information we the only thing that would
reassure me would be a non-partisan
would have to be somebody who you know
didn't have a political slant and maybe
multiple evaluators but a nonpartisan
neuropsychological in depth many hours
evaluation that's the only thing that
would satisfy me at this point to really
be reassured that the American people
are in safe hands with this president
we've been speaking to dr. Steven Boozer
he's a clinical psychiatrist former
major in the United States Air Force and
he also edited with Leonard cruise the
book a clear and present danger
narcissism in the era of President Trump
thanks so much for sharing your insights
today thank you so much David we really
appreciate it